[Music]
[Music]
good rancher
our deepest fear is not that we're
inadequate it's that we're too good and
we fear how good we are that's why you
can't be afraid
get out there and lay those fancy eggs i
love you all
individually and as a group
i love you i love you
that's it
you did it you're learning to speak
human
bad rancher
got some food for you yeah i'm sure
daddy ranch was in a bad mood last time
but you've been doing good work on the i
don't even need any eggs yeah come on
come on up to the door that's it
and just stay right there
don't go with the bad rancher go with
the good ranchers 100 american
steakhouse quality meat subscribe today
at goodranchers.com crowder and lock in
your 25 off every box for the entire
life of your subscription
good ranchers american meat delivered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to cultural appropriations
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
oh wait i forgot i have the
my stress ball in my uh
what on earth do i have to be stressed
about nothing
uh a lot going on actually we won the
youtube thing so that's we're good was
just a false claim yeah it was a false
claim just so you guys thanks guys
before i go on to anything else because
we have been removed for discussing gun
issues in the past you can watch the
show monday through friday at 10 a.m
eastern start monday through thursday 10
am eastern uh on rumble running up there
rumble or mug club today we'll be
playing pokemon or racial slur yeah i'm
surprised we're still here after
yesterday to be honest yes yeah
well that's a win it remains to be seen
and by that i mean we absolutely will
see so uh look we're going to get right
into matthew mcconaughey right now he's
trending and some of us here in the
studio disagreed
be care beware the wolf in sheep's
clothing so we've pulled some archived
footage so you know exactly where this
guy is lining up on
gun control on these proposals because
there are a lot of proposals that you
will hear that seem reasonable on their
surface and this is what we've talked
about in the past and i hope if nothing
else the references that we make
available to you uh always on
lotterycredit.com uh help you to
understand the policies versus the
rhetoric if someone says something like
oh we're red flag those that sounds good
okay what's the policy proposal we've
talked about this in the past where they
say dreamers children they shouldn't be
deported if they were born here okay
sure got it so is that oh no wait you
don't believe in deporting anyone
including violent felons who are
overcrowding our prisons who are here
illegally so it's not about what someone
says it is about the actual legislation
being proposed and how it's been used in
the past or if there's a precedent set
in some other country so we'll be
talking about that with matthew
mcconaughey my question to you before we
move on to anything else is do you trust
matthew mcconaughey
do you think his proposals are
reasonable
and also something else i bit my cheek
did you earlier this week and it's have
you ever done that and then you bite
your cheek five more times that week
because it you know it gets bigger and
more swollen yes yeah so if i talk like
this it's like aoc i'm doing my best
just know why i have a giant lump in my
cheek that is now a canker sore okay
i'm not sure
also pressed for joe lewis i stayed up
all night he was pooping all over the
place i hope he just got into something
he was so nice he went to the upstairs
bathroom in the corner and i walked in
the house
i smelled poop
and then i couldn't find it and i mean
it was it was a mess but he he tried to
use the corner i don't understand how
using the furthest corner from you
was nice because maybe you wouldn't
notice it and then days later you're
like huh well that was a thing he didn't
want it he didn't want to be a san
francisco street urchin you know what
you guys take notes see the animals use
the corner
san francisco at least he's in the
bathroom yeah i mean that is a step up i
think that was a just a pure chance i
don't think he knows it twice
throughout the night he would find a
corner and do it so i am grateful
really i think he's a you know good
little guy doing that before he's trying
to be considerate on the wall he's sick
it's the first time we've had that
accident all right we don't need to talk
about more
unfortunately we just our viewership in
germany just went up threefold so yeah
this cultural appropriation already they
must be doing germany was he dressed
like a nun yes
did he fly
all right you know him you love him very
smart man got a voice for radio and has
a face only a mother could love gerald a
how are you i'm doing well
i cannot help but laugh how are you
doing other than being covered in feces
i'm not covered in feces well i think
what do your fantasies have to do with
it i know
you just told the stories about your dog
pooping in every corner of the house i
didn't say on me and appreciating it i
appreciate that he didn't just let it
fall wherever he is walking like someone
in san francisco keep trying to dig out
of that he didn't roll in it no no
what better situation can you ask for a
dog who's sick
pooping outside
yeah but i was gone and i was gone for
like two i was gone for two hours yes
but i'm saying if you're gone from the
house can you guys can you guys let
gerald know like honestly that is what
kind of a stan this is why you don't
have dogs you shouldn't no there's a dog
should have driven to the store and got
a modium pretty much maybe some pepto
yeah
quit being useless what happened
uh all right and then uh the quickest
wit uh in the west fastest man on his
feet he is going to be in des moines
iowa uh actually june 10th this weekend
uh you can always go look at tickets uh
on tour uh i guess we'll dave landau.com
because we don't have one on the lotto
crowd.com tour site but big announcement
for the fall tour him and i together
yeah next week that's huge right now
he's solo go see him dave linda ahoy
this weekend come on come out des moines
yeah you really have nothing better to
do i was going to say really like
nothing we don't want to insult your
town but
i've seen des moines what are we gonna
do
run through a cornfield and pretend it's
boys yeah or just
just lie
that's what you have to do if you just
you know and by by that i mean she's
like oh no des moines is actually not
that bad that's something you just lie
you'd be like oh yeah no i've been there
yeah it's uh
hey i haven't used insult a place too
and they're like yeah you host detroit
like to get mad at you where you're from
and you're like i'm aware it's terrible
yes exactly i know i said it wasn't that
i don't find my identity in the
geographic location of my birth
that's the same thing with team sports
like guys who play for our geographic
location who weren't born there or even
live there are beating the guys from
your geographic locations like all of
your players are from 2000 miles away
yeah thank you for king my car i can't
even tell you all the positions in
football right yeah yeah really
appreciate it i don't know maybe one of
them is left here
good i'm glad i brought michigan plates
to ohio i really deserve that
oh if you bring illinois place to
michigan too they don't oh they're there
oh they are no michigan's terrible too
yeah michigan's awful
everybody who's from anywhere is awful
worst governor in the country um thank
god the fbi was not successful in
kidnapping her that's true now
or the new guy who
had her on a hit list from what i read
uh yeah i'm willing to bet also fbi
maybe cia who knows one of those three
letter agencies one of the fellows so
before we go on later and we're going to
talk about the fbi ncaa and simone biles
uh suing uh nassar for a billion dollars
for not doing enough and suiting the fbi
yeah he's suing the fbi yeah and she
says they're not doing enough i'm
i think that they actually did their job
perfectly
if you're if you're going by what they
intended to do and we'll build that case
here with the fbi cia in a long and
storied history of uh you know child
predators and child pornography and uh
all references available at lotto.com
but before that let's set this up this
was just on cnn this morning dwyane wade
plays basketball this is the one with
slam dunks correct yes and uh he was
talking with poppy harlow
about school shootings and everyone is
jumping on this bandwagon because they
feel as though it's politically safe and
they're out of touch with the majority
of americans who support second
amendment rights and gun ownership so
here he is uh talking out of his ass i
think about this when we grew up we went
to school it was just hey kids off to
school that is the safest place to be
don't be out on the street go to school
i wait for three o'clock every day
yeah i'm afraid being here
and not being in la close to my kids now
we were just talking about this at lunch
like you just you know like i and just
to share a story i went to my daughter
zaya's recital at the end of the year
and beautiful recital these kids worked
amazing they worked hard for this but
the whole time i like the thing about it
yeah why is he dressed like the mayor of
america
my daughter's backstage my son's right
here
how do i get out how do i get out how do
i get to them how do i protect them
saying that schools are no longer safe i
mean well i guess if you count the girls
bathrooms
so this is one of those things they want
to that's uh that's uh that's the sun
is it i don't know if it's a girl
dressed up as a boy the point is this uh
she doesn't even agree with him in that
clip do you notice that he's like i was
school to save this place she's like i
was waiting to three every day and that
oh implies that she wanted to leave
school and he just continues like yeah
i'm just gonna continue like you
agreeing with my point
[Applause]
you're always embarrassed of your
parents yeah yeah i love how he's like i
can't believe i'm not near my kids in
the safest place in the world l.a
right i'm just wondering what school did
he go to yeah like i thought i thought
you were you know a little more
i thought a little more rough and tumble
than that no i don't think he's a
basketball player ah yes
well any school wasn't that safe for
many reasons no no they're not that safe
and by the way you shouldn't
what he is also conveying there is
oh school is
substan it's de facto parenting yeah
look you would like to think so but it's
not even necessarily the police's job to
keep you safe you understand that right
we've seen that we see more stories
coming it's not the school's job to
guarantee the safety of your child we'd
like to think that they do it's your job
as a parent and that's why it's more
important to give this authority back to
parents what does the left want to do
the left is against charter schools the
left doesn't believe in school choice
school vouchers the left has a war
against homeschooling yeah be difficult
to find an argument a case to be made
for homeschooling in 2022. and then we
talk about common ground well wait a
second how about common ground yeah you
know we said there's a problem with
schools i know you want to throw more
money at it and say that there should
not be teachers who are allowed to
protect themselves
we just think that maybe public schools
maybe the federal department of
education is a broken system if you
listen to what these people are saying
they're either being dishonest
or they don't know what they're saying
and we'll get to matthew mcconaughey i
don't know which it is i'm curious i
would love to hear you your feedback
below if you think that matthew
mcconaughey is just an unintelligent
person and comment below or if you think
that uh he's deliberately misleading
okay well he's an actor yes and in
fairness to the left
he's an actor
because that makes it okay i i didn't
know until i came here today the white
house i thought it was i thought it was
a set i thought it was a woozy it was
wise it was
fair it does
watch him when he's making his points he
said
and that's why we need responsible gun
ownership
you'll see it and you're like oh you
really think that was
sure boom are you an acid all the time
every day oh yeah all right every day
all right i would stay here longer right
all right play the
bongos i got no clothes on none at all
so here's something else while we're
talking about the moral decay of our
society who could have imagined that we
would have a mental health crisis who
could have possibly predicted oh that's
right they were removed as episodes from
youtube this is this is why you can go
watch the band episodes on mug club when
we talked about the dangers of lockdowns
and covid and children and remember in
that show that was where you cited the
cdc death stats for children i will
never do it again forced home school as
opposed to chosen homes right yeah yeah
i forgot also therefore you can't
socialize them anywhere else because
those were also shut down that's correct
yeah that's okay though right right and
that was the episode that was removed
because gerald cited the cdc studies the
cdc numbers on deaths from covet and
then said let's juxtapose that with what
we are seeing as this dramatic increase
in substance abuse suicide teen
depression we talked about it then
and now well we're back to it's uh the
ar-15s fault and by the way we'll get to
this i've talked about it before but
there's new data the united states is
not the top country in the world or the
top country in the first world which now
apparently applies because you
acknowledge that these other countries
like honduras el salvador shitholes uh
we're not the top country for mass
shootings the trend elsewhere in the
world is going up and the united states
is either stagnant or it's going down
we'll have the stat available for you
later so all of these people jumping on
the bandwagon they're doing it based on
a lie and then they're proposing
policies that are entirely misleading
that's what you need to know and we'll
try and keep it succinct for you as we
talk about the moral decay of our
society and by that i mean uh just
society today in general and i know we
did have a point in this country it's
not lost on me okay we'll survive this
we had a civil war i understand that
but there has never been a point in our
history where the elites in power have
tried to entirely change the foundation
of our cult the cultural basis of our
society sure we had a civil war but we
still thought that men were a thing and
women were a thing and that children
should be protected and they shouldn't
be the target of sexualized content this
was this is a very very big change i get
that you can talk about violence and war
but we have never been at this kind of a
phase in our country and so if if you
feel like this is severe it is severe
two things can be true we've had more
violent turbulent times but this is
uncharted territory and i think it's
important to cover all of it so this
happened at being so obvious without
anybody caring i know that's the thing
that's so strange you know the thing is
people do care that's the problem it's
the people in power disproportionate
power that's cancelled culture is not
the people canceled culture is not even
at this point it's no longer the mob
it's
it's the mafia is what it is the mob of
torch and pitchforks you think you know
the people right the citizens out there
they're angry kill the beast no it's the
mafia behind the scenes the people
who've never held private office or at
least for the last several decades who
decide that oh you know what uh we're
just going to
ban
guns that are used in less than five
percent of shootings we're just going to
arbitrarily pick a magazine you know
what we're just going to decide that you
don't get school lunches for uh you
don't get any federal funding if you
don't allow boys into girls rooms most
americans are not on board with it
that's the issue you have the president
saying the most important thing you can
do is affirm the gender of your child
meaning puberty blockers meaning cross
hormone sex replacement therapy meaning
uh gender reassignment surgery most
americans are going
at six but unfortunately they try to
they try to stifle your voice and
amplify theirs that's what's so
different about right now now
i hear you got a problem i gotta move on
i gotta move on here dave uh
this past sunday service at uh joel
osteen the lakewood church
um so this is something else was crashed
by
two
i'm gonna say this alleged
because i spent a lot of time with the
sears wish list catalog as a kid this
was before we had the internet in the jc
penney's catalog there are plus sizes
models that's not my primary issue with
these ladies oh so alleged j.c penny
catalog models were uh protesting uh at
uh the church here you go
never never never i'll never be the same
in jesus name god bless you
it's my body
my
choice
i don't know she was late to take off
her shirt
let's see what happens to her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
none of that's paint that's the weird
part yes bye felicia
um
i mean again when we talk about
political theater something that
accomplishes nothing yeah
we have breakout sessions here we say
okay what can we do what do we think is
the most effective segment how do we
frame it how do we make sure that we're
accurate with our references if we're
going to go on location like a beto
event we're doing it change my mind they
sat there and it made it like i know
we will
wear granny panties at joel osteen's
church and strip naked almost that will
show them
and this might seem bad but this kind of
stuff you know it happens a lot you just
don't hear about it there was um was it
just yesterday there was a similar
incident at uh was it mattis yahoo's
temple
in tel aviv yeah
[Applause]
it's my butthole my choice
[Applause]
wow
casey i had no idea that tattoos what
did you grow up in a russian prison yeah
are you in the white yakuza i knew you
played guitar i know you got tattoos
with the strings of them
zip it
i could have sworn that gibbon just got
married i mean maybe this is all
covered and in a lighter right oh you
can tell that was definitely honeymoon
bud
i just want to say what i think we're
all thinking in here those were a couple
of real hunky gay israelis yes yes gays
gay israelis yeah yeah
because that guy is going to be buried
in a jewish cemetery yeah
face down maybe
so
speaking of protesters who do nothing
and i'm not at matthew mcconaughey yet
uh tuesday there were several um there
were several uh
look people can do whatever they want
okay there are big girls and these were
protesters they're big girls there's two
very big there were some very big girls
and they stormed the court at the
barclays center
[Applause]
somebody tackle like form tackle
dragging that one i love it
that's a huge [ __ ] how many girls have
paid for the abortion or
basketball players have paid for the
abortion i know
well hold on right now this is a wnba
game so if you're picking a place to go
in protest let's go to the one that can
barely fill up the lower bowl of an
arena well they figured that they could
probably make it onto the court because
there's so they could yes they're like
ah who's gonna care about this but it's
not even like really televised even
though espn tries to make you think it
is yeah
so it's like oh gosh oh they were just
in shape enough to not get past security
right yes
there were six other larger people who
never got it onto the court because they
were doing the inhaler yeah well when
they were taking them they were
escorting them off the court several of
them had to take a break
[Laughter]
here a couple of things too this is one
thing you hear about my body my choice
my body my choice
i hear this a lot from the left as it
relates to women right republicans
conservatives they don't even want you
to decide what you can do with your own
body well i understand they're talking
about abortion all right let's just
let's just put that on the back burner
for a second okay regardless of your
opinion
how about every other issue that
revolves around choice every other one
where is the left supporting women to
have more individual choice which school
you can go to no
right which car you can drive no
what you can do with your own money no
take any issue
that revolves around basic basic
sovereignty and freedom what kind of gun
you can own no
well you can even have a gun whether you
can have a gun no rapist or an attacker
so it's just abortion i'm a woman they
want to take away tracer no look you
don't care about choice in any other
facet certainly not these left you're
just discussing
abortion which again you would just even
if you disagree you would have to
acknowledge that it's ideologically
consistent for someone on the right to
say well look we believe in supporting
your right to choose everything else we
just don't believe in your right to
choose for someone else and we believe
through a scientific
uh method of question that that's
another life that baby in your body
that's it the left doesn't believe in
choice for anything that's primarily
what we [ __ ] about on this show
so anyways these back to the wnba uh
slash spirit airlines boarding call
it is the spirit airlines of the
basketball world i love it one of them
grabs their hair right away oh nothing
like perpetuating the original
stereotype that was an it was a really
cool steel still picture and in the
background you see guys like
yeah
is somebody really
all that pro
life at the wnba i don't understand the
protest i would imagine they're
probably pro-suicide if they're the w
really i mean i know they're proud
probably right yeah i mean the wnba game
is our equivalent of the traveling
japanese suicide forest i mean way more
people noticed that than in the church
because nobody was paying attention to
the game right you were like oh yeah yes
look at this that's weird but there's
more nonsense yes exactly yeah oh i'm
really glad i got these free tickets at
the office party yeah otherwise i would
have missed fat chicks with fate with
face paint on their tits yeah can you
believe these were just at the gas
station there by the register for free
please take professional sporting event
and the highlight is the balloon animals
yeah that was the most exciting part of
that game
yeah who won i don't know me i saw a fat
girl get beaten up yeah no way who was
playing out of the the cincinnati
the cincinnati bankrupt i think i don't
know
how do we how do you notice how they
playing the phoenix chapter 11 yeah that
was the new york poor investments yeah
you know how they titled around there so
like yeah let's say that they crashed
the game well nobody will know what the
game is
go to the barclays center they know the
buildings there
yeah
yeah that'll work
so uh they came with some banners these
uh
these uh these these tits scallions
uh and the sign said overturn row hell
no that's a nice rhyme yeah abortion on
demand and without apology well there
you go there's the message that they're
actually uh they're actually proclaiming
there
how about how about some apology how
about just a little bit how about a
little bit of shame what did you do that
what did you do
like what did you go home and you're
like yeah we showed them yeah right you
showed them what you showed them what
well we showed them half of our boobs
yeah which they didn't like and so we
really feel like you know that we we
thrust something in front of them
without their consent that they didn't
want to see and so we think
that we'll take the little ones yeah
we show them why our doctor goes you
know what just do whatever you want yes
just do whatever hey you know what you
know what these guys pay for on the
weekend we did that for free at a game
yes you know and they go and look at
people yeah we showed them what they
wanted to see not us but other things
that they want to see yeah and uh yeah
that that'll get them like this is the
best form of protest ever for women
is just to strip down and run through
the streets well here's the thing they
sort of i will say this they were
playing 8d chess because initially we
always you know we were like hey you
know women if you're going to protest
uh patriarchy don't show your boobs
don't do free the nipple thursday like
they do every year they don't burn it so
you never get it back right don't don't
burn your bras and show oh put those
away but then they were playing 8d chest
and like we're going to show you the
boobs that you specifically don't want
to see and we're like well this really
backfired we didn't foresee this he
didn't realize a.d chess was hungry
hungry hippos
[Laughter]
so the group
is called rise up for abortion rights i
made a a statement on twitter afterward
we are calling on those who can stop the
overturning of roe v wade the millions
of people who support abortion rights oh
my god i just looked at the overlay
that's not far off from what they
actually look like i didn't mean to make
the groan it was just there as well when
i saw it it says no business as usual
shut the country down
what
this is again this you want to know how
we reached the point where businesses
were shut down and we decimated the
economy
these land whales want to shut it down
if they're not getting taxpayer-funded
abortions for the sex they're clearly
not having
i also love that they're called rise up
i don't think they're rising quickly no
i don't think anyone else is rising up
for them at all
staying soft yeah i should be called
don't worry it happens to lots of guys
for abortion rights
you're telling me somebody got you
pregnant yeah no yeah why don't you
spend the time buying a condom and then
never ever giving it to a guy right yeah
exactly
just open it up it just disintegrates
yeah oh like kaneki in greece
and the guy's like oh rats i guess i
have to leave yeah
we don't have to practice responsible
sex oh no we don't no don't let me off
the hook on this one you're a strong
woman
i'm going to go and i'm just going to
keep my back to the door yes
so this is this is obviously a radical
abortion activist group uh there and
there's another more radical abortion
activist group that they're taking a
more i guess you you should say direct
approach um tuesday morning a compass
care which is like a crisis pregnancy
center in buffalo um
it was firebombed jeez wow and uh
amherst pd issued a statement saying the
fire is being investigated as arson at
this time
um
isn't uh
i mean isn't arson it's a fire i guess
yes so that is known we don't know
if the fire if we don't know if the
arsonist used fire well then they
wouldn't be an arsonist yeah we're not
sure i guess we're not sure if the fire
was a fire but we're looking we're
looking into it and we'll get back to
you uh we can't find our cops right now
because they're hiding while children
need them yes we cannot confirm nor deny
if it was a fire yes we saw flames
though and it looks like burnt yes
[Music]
well it sounds like there was a fire
here
yeah i don't know though i'm gonna get
kojak on this yeah i'm only a literal
fire professional right but i don't know
so the building was vandalized with
these words that jane was here which is
of course a reference to gene's revenge
and they called for a night of rage when
the supreme court um issued the decision
or it was leaked i believe the dobbs
versus mississippi this is uh from them
said whatever form your fury takes the
first step is feeling it the next step
is carrying that anger out into the
world and expressing it physically on
the night the final ruling is issued we
are asking for courageous hearts to come
out after dark to make your anger known
when we talk about insurrection we talk
about what happened in january 6th yeah
um
look it's a do we need to we're talking
about billions of dollars in damage is
this a surprise this is what happened
with black lives matter the riots but
right now it's right there hey look you
want to talk about red flag laws we'll
get to that in a second how about people
saying let your rage be known go out and
we're gonna we're gonna fire bomb a
crisis pregnancy center yeah they can't
even say oh what we said is uh basically
just go out and yell no you said
physically you said physically there by
the way watch all of the politicians
that run out into the streets and say
this is what happens this is the rage
that the population feels this is what
you get when you do this like they did
with blm right watch for it yeah that's
you know how many times on this show
i've had to say figuratively for
something that was clearly meant
figuratively
it's like oh you mean you mean bomb uh
crisis pregnancy centers figuratively no
i mean i mean physically
fbi
anyone you're too busy looking at your
child porn on your computers mr c.i.a
all right great oh and there's another
firebomb fantastic maybe you want to
investigate that one is arson look we're
going to physically burn these too oh
geez figuratively is there another
garage pool you need to go look at okay
yeah we heard
guys they have a lot of child
pornography yes they really heard
they've been hanging lawn ornaments and
yeah outside of race car [ __ ] we are
investigating the matter of arson do you
mean you read their mail uh blast out
did you check their facebook page where
they said we are going to commit arson
tonight at this location they're like
the wet bandits yeah
it's a calling card you could have gone
there and stopped him well
who's gonna look at the child porn come
on yeah not superman yeah
somebody's got to stay here and do that
let's think of that let's move on here
to the fbi by the way hit the like
button if you're watching on youtube uh
because guess what the fbi is not a fan
we told you they tried to sting us one
of those guys at the fbi failed yeah
failed
turned out they're like ah they're just
kind of christian conservative guys
there who believe in limited government
but they're not yeah we had an fbi guy
one who was involved with the kidnapping
whitmer plot
try to get behind the scenes here we had
no idea we're like oh that guy
disappeared whatever happened to that uh
fbi agent i don't know then i read about
them in the news i said you're
bullshitting
i don't care go ahead target us whatever
you think what do you think this is
you know where we stand it's very clear
there's hours and hours of footage on
where we stand
so i've read my texts they're really
cleaner than this show right
and this was not dirty by the way so
simone biles i don't know if you've been
following us while we're talking she's
the one that the nasser fingered yeah
wow did i say that wrong allegedly
allegedly yeah but point it out put it
out point it out you know what i meant
in a lineup yeah right
although it's pretty easy to point
around because like she's a gymnast and
so you're like is it uh the one hold on
we have uh is it number one number two
or four
or five like that's the one who's not
five foot
there we go there we go yeah it's the
one who's stretching with her feet
behind her head yes has chalk on her
hands so simone biles um and uh 90 other
women right now filed federal tort
claims against the fbi uh they are
seeking a billion dollars in damages
this is that you know uh nassar abused
them um
after allegations were reported in 2015.
so it's important note that there are
allegations this is something that was
going on nothing was done and then abuse
continued to take place that is
important because i do think it's tough
to go after the fbi and just say why
didn't you do anything and i say how
could we know in this case it's like
how could we know because we told you
and then it it kept happening yeah like
oh i do see your point
they didn't say that of course not
they're claiming that well what do you
expect us to do
investigate it's in the name just
because we have the proof yeah what are
we supposed to do stop them right i mean
we're busy investigating arson come on
yeah how am i going to figure out if
this is a fire if i got to stop that guy
from uh having sex with people i mean
you know it's like what oh my god what
do you think i only have two hands yeah
come on
yeah
one of them's occupied i usually switch
off one of them's got to turn the
computer on right you know what i mean
oh my god did we have a clip of them
jergens isn't going to buy itself uh
yeah we do have a clip by the way this
is going back when was this clip is this
clip from
2 000.
2021. this is from 2020.
in the case this was a testimony in the
case that we covered and now they're
seeking a billion dollars in damages but
here's pretty powerful testimony over
the past few years it has become
painfully clear
how a survivor's healing is affected by
the handling of their abuse
and it disgusts me
that we are still fighting for the most
basic answers and accountability over
six
years
later to be clear
sorry
take your time
to be clear i blame larry nassar
and i also blame
an entire system
that enabled and
perpetrated his abuse
usa gymnastics in the united states
olympic and paralympic community
committee
knew that i was abused by their official
team doctor long before i was ever made
aware of their knowledge
now look we want to find common ground
here's the reason we can't is because if
we so mistrust in institutions you blame
us for sowing mistrust in institutions
whereas i think you should blame the
institutions themselves look i don't
need to believe that the fbi is
systemically racist they also sexually
assaulted white girls sexually assaulted
biracial girls asian american girls
right just to be clear there are a lot
of women who are sexually abused to
understand a systemic problem with these
institutions is simply to understand
that they only look out for the interest
of these systemic institutions
the fbi doesn't exist to serve you the
fbi exists to send in a spreadsheet at
the end of the year and say look at it
look at what a great job we're doing
boss
yeah no one wants to report when when
the agencies are responsible for
reporting
you can't count on them to report on
themselves for mishandling yeah who
investigates them i know that they have
internal groups but just to be clear we
covered the trial this was kind of a
rehash of the testimony to congress
saying look
we blame the guy who did this but we
told you about this yes we told you this
was the problem at best the fbi is
incredibly broken that is the very best
case scenario and here's the thing when
people say believe all women i don't
know have you spent time with a lot of
women you shouldn't believe all women
but in this case where you have 90 who
come forward and they say this is what's
happening now they did it the right way
they came forward and they reported it
to the authorities now you can't blame
rape culture
for nothing happening
we've always said if you are sexually
assaulted plea you need to come forward
right away yeah make sure because we
want these people buried beneath the
prison actual rapists actual people who
prey on the young and the vulnerable in
this case they did it the right way they
went forward it wasn't in a washington
post article it wasn't a tweet
and the people who by the way many
believe should be the only ones with
guns and those responsible for
protecting us did nothing for years and
this is something else this doesn't just
exist
uh these things aren't just siloed okay
the fbi and the cia these three letter
agencies they have a long history of
mishandling and
outright committing
what
we would call sex sex crimes sex
offenses themselves so remember the fbi
ignored um the uh child abuse on the
indian reservation yeah north dakota and
they fired the whistleblower jane turner
ah there you go
that's doing their job right yeah this
was uh this is a quote here from
national whistleblower center in
retaliation for exposing fbi failures
within its child program jane turner was
removed from senior resident agent
position uh four fbi agents had sex with
prostitutes over teas overseas and over
teats overseas and lied about it now
what about the cia
i know sometimes they sort of bleed
together in your mind right the past 14
years there have been at least 10 cia
contractors who committed sex crimes
involving children
remember we talked about this one had
sexual contact with a two-year-old and a
six-year-old
three sexual abuse videos of young girls
that were filmed by their mothers and
there was another who viewed more than
fourteen hundred kiddie porn images
while on an assignment remember these
were on cia computers
yeah so much more who are you hiring
i use a vpn yeah
that's why we lost the sponsor yes well
stop using it for that well what's it
for we can see that i just want to make
a really cool point here we've told
women to come forward right we've told
them to come forward because we want to
get the perpetrators but we want to get
them the help that they need exactly and
we want to stop the problem so put
yourself in the position of the people
who came forward and said this is
happening guess what happened next week
they went in larry nasa was there next
week larry nassar was there next week
larry larry nassar was there
then they're hearing from their
teammates he did it to me he did it to
me yep he did it to me what you have
just done is not just keep the problem
in place
you have made that person's soul
probably die i came forward nothing
happened and now i have to see that
person
every time i come in and i pray to god i
don't have to go and get therapy from
that guy
that's what you've done by not taking
out this is what's crazy think about it
you have these abortion groups we were
just talking about saying let your rage
be known and encouraging physically
violent behavior right against those who
might even support the supreme court
decision on roe v wade
but you don't have you would have people
be more offended if parents violently
ended larry nassar
yeah yeah that's true which they should
have like if cain velasquez maybe had
redirected well a lot of the time and
this obviously doesn't go in every
single case but you know somebody tweets
something out 20 years later there's a
good chance it's iffy right when you
have 90 people coming out while it is
happening or has just happened there's a
very good chance
even if it's one person yeah that's
going on yeah because that is what most
victims who seem to really be authentic
do they come out right away because
they're terrified and he didn't do this
in secret he did it with moms in the
room he gave them a vaginal massage on
the inside because he said it was sports
therapy yeah this wasn't rocket science
to figure out that this was going on
well this is also the problem with you
know child star parents and you have the
same syndrome with athletes parents who
want their kids to be really successful
we'd like to think that all parents out
there are looking out for the best
interest of their children but not all
of them are as seen by them still
putting kids in public schools because
it's more important to not have to pay
an extra dollar than to actually make
sure that your kids are safe and being
taught right from wrong and so you have
these parents who when their kids were
saying i don't think this is right mom
it's like well do you want to make the
olympics
so this is a failure
on many parts and i will say it's a
failure on of course uh the parents the
main failure is with larry nassar it's a
failure on these institutions who you
should trust by the way who are also
involved with fact checking right the
fbi the doj the cia they take part in
big texts determining of what is
information right now they're busy going
after people with a face paint who are
on january 6th as opposed to someone who
sexually assaulted 90 women and or girls
i should say
and it is the fault
of a lot of men out there
look people talk about this you think
think i give women a hard time i don't
give women anywhere near as hard of a
time as the men i'm always amazed that a
dad or a husband didn't kick the [ __ ]
out of 90
90. hey no one ever kicked harvey
weinstein's ass
are you calling for violence can someone
who commits sexual assault against 90
people uh yeah
if someone said that was my niece i
would be like all right so we got to go
over there right right like i just i
don't understand exactly that's how
everything is oh i thought that's just
how you handle something right
yeah like it looks like the hell's
angels need to make a uh a run for toys
for pummel horsing oh yeah i'll call the
cops do it yeah go tell them what you
did and tell them why we're here yeah
exactly here here's the phone they
already know as they see you get thrown
out of the third story window they'll
cuff you when you land in the bushes
safely but what hand do you deal with
and the problem is this it's not again
when we look at the problem we see a
problem with organizations we see a
problem with uh
you see a problem with these
institutions not with individuals i'm
willing to bet that there were probably
some individual police officers new
valede who wanted to do the right thing
and they couldn't yes i'm willing to bet
there were probably people at the fbi
who wanted to do the right thing and
they couldn't but the solution from the
left is all and i and i'm
being very prudent here you don't want
to speak in absolutes politically the
solutions from the left
outside of abortion choice is always
more institutions and more power to them
find me an example
from a democrat that says we need to
disband the fbi the cia or we need to
reduce the centralized authority of
these agencies find me one proposal you
won't
now we want people to make more
individual choices as citizens to put
that power back in their hand but i also
just think look anytime you get an
institution that grows to i don't know
how many billions of dollars a year in
budget and we can't know either because
it's always misreported because who
reports it themselves who holds them
accountable no one else we have a
problem
how many examples do you have to see
from local police departments where
people are more concerned about their
pension and not pissing off the chief
to the world's best the best of the best
right you want to think about that you
want to think about our us marshals this
way the fbi you watch the fugitive you
watch these films the fbi they show up
they're the good guy
no not really not really not anymore and
you certainly shouldn't give them blind
trust they've given you every reason to
mistrust them and it's not our fault
that you mistrust institutions anymore
that it's our fault brian stelter is
getting fired that one's not on me brian
we are hiring and i will pay you very
handsomely that's not a joke hey we have
a breaking story that lane just sent in
this happened this morning ginger snap
handsome involving him yes
the ladies love him in the chat oh
that's disgusting so a gunman was
arrested near justice kavanaugh's
residence sorry early this morning and
when police detained him he said he was
there to kill kavanaugh
and you'll remember that kavanaugh's
residence was the site of protest for
the ravi wade legal documents by the way
some of them were started by his uh
neighbor hey uh
i wonder how long that investigation is
going to be like well uh why was he
there well we're running an
investigation hold on a second why were
you there i was there to kill kavanaugh
listen we need to take our time yeah
wait let this process play out
trust the fbi have you ever seen a movie
let's do it like that yeah they want you
to think that their coach actually hey
who loves you baby
which hey so i have a question which
politician do we we subpoena before
congress to talk about them saying that
you should go out in the streets and
that you should you know make your
voices heard and all that stuff and
incite violence i mean i i know that
they did that with donald trump when he
said peacefully and you know make your
voices heard patriotic just so happens
you said which politician casey has a
new quote on the sound board which
politician i think you know what i'm
talking about casey which one hit the
putt
[Laughter]
you he's you had one job you had a
politician we've had this conversation
for the last three days the new sound
board quote there's a soundboard quote
of a politician no not about politician
about oh it's not romney right it's gary
oldman for christ
well that was a little odd which
politician should we subpoena every one
a little late but he got to the game
gotta spell it out for you what do you
work for the fbi i'm
it counter-retarded like he doesn't even
have a voice he just speaks through the
uh it just speaks to the soundboard yeah
i mentioned him every day haven't we
yeah not against casey i just forgot
that we have brought him up every year
and now i just instead of churchill i
just picture gary yeah exactly me too
here's the thing we all just heard the
story right bring that back up there uh
tokinon it's right kavanaugh some with a
gun saying i want to kill cavanaugh okay
we just saw this story live
first off i'm not seeing anything on cnn
second anyone in this studio go oh
we need gun control no right away we go
that's a person who's a problem we have
a problem with people we have a problem
with institutions and politicians saying
go forward and write and you have kamala
harris the president of the united
states saying they should riot they
should continue to riot this is how they
they make themselves heard
who could have seen this possibly coming
who could have seen coming let's say i
don't know two weeks ago a month ago
kavanaugh was going to have someone try
to kill him yeah i mean we're not no we
don't have a crystal ball well not only
that we didn't even flinch we just
immediately made a joke about it because
it's not that shocking right it's like
oh there's a guy trying to kill kevin on
his neighborhood that's oh stunning all
right i would have never seen it we need
to move on to matthew mcconaughey here
but uh look you saw that ad uh just
there at the beginning i am so good
ranchers
good rancher is unbelievable their steak
is incredible and the father day is
coming up you have a limited there's a
deal right now actually you get two free
18-ounce ribeye steaks with a promo code
crowder that's awesome if you enter that
in is it good rancher dot
goodrancher.com is that where they go
goodranchers.com
there's more than one good rancher
steven there are several several but
they're limited they are
not you met some ranchers
yeah oh man there's a couple of good
ranchers but uh it really is a great
company if you check out the instagram
two they have the balls to stand up
politically and their all of their beef
is usda uh prime 100 american steakhouse
quality uh or better so usda prime or
better and you know what they cut out
the middleman so you get a better price
it's a better price right now wasn't
always this way
i used to try and have to tell you like
hey their prices are at least as good as
your grocery store only it's more
convenient and it's better quality meat
it's it's more uh affordable than your
local grocery store right now because of
inflation because of what they do with
their local ranchers compare the prices
and you get two free rib eyes you center
in the promo code track 15-ounce
turbines that's a that's a hefty stick
that'll tip over fred flinstone's car
yeah that is a hefty one
that'll run into a wnba game and show
its tips
also it'll be put on the eye of the wnba
protester afterwards yes exactly can i
borrow that
the hair
just the ghetto snakes
for the cord
no pulling hair it's just weaves and
wide set tampons
this is professional sports lovely i
never called them ghetto snakes so i
would walk through new york and
everybody called them ghetto snakes yeah
i was like oh that makes sense we
present you the wnba world champions
yeah unless they play a high school boys
team then i guess
well i don't have to give away that
trophy number two mail it
all right so matthew mcconaughey also uh
if you share this that helps here on
youtube because the algorithms right now
it's like
you're subscribed notifications we know
they don't work that's why we say tune
in monday through thursday just bookmark
it come in sharing seems to help so
matthew mcconaughey he's in the press
right now uh because he went to the
white house with the new press secretary
i always have to get used to saying the
name of jean-pierre jean-pierre because
she doesn't look like a jump here
i agree you wouldn't expect it no i
don't know if that's a tv name if that's
a press secretary name it looks more
like a clouseau right yeah exactly i go
with more than that
she's full of [ __ ]
yeah he's inept
so um he was there to
jump on the lie and i'll get to that at
the end the lie of this uh you know this
mass shooting epidemic but uh here he
was talking about his hometown when he's
not claiming his hometown is austin and
i get that he he's likable and i got
that a lot of people think that he's
down the middle because he's been on the
podcast and i know he's very he was very
respectful with jordan peterson and i
think russell brand i i understand he's
made the rounds
but i also know his past i also know his
history and i also know to read between
the lines as to what he's suggesting
here so this is mcconaughey don't be
fooled talking about uvalde and
trying to present it as common sense
common ground gun reform
you know what
every one of these parents wanted what
they asked us for but every parent
separately expressed in their own way to
camilla and me
that they want their children's dreams
to live on
that they want their children's dreams
to continue
to accomplish something after they are
gone
they want to make
their loss of life
matter
families of the deceased mothers fathers
sisters brothers texas rangers hunters
border patrol and responsible gun owners
who won't give up their second amendment
right to bear arms and you know what
they all said
we want secure and safe schools and we
want gun laws that won't make it so easy
for the bad guys to get these damn guns
that's a lot of saying something with
saying nothing now here's the thing
we're going to get into his proposals
which a lot of people unfortunately i've
seen some folks on the right say well
you know what i think this might be uh
sensible okay
it is a trojan horse
let me explain to you exactly why let me
show you exactly why because we'll get
to what he's proposing now but here he
is less than four years ago with the
march for our lives the david hogg crap
after the parkland shooting telling you
exactly where he actually lines up and
what he wants sort of the beta o'rourke
syndrome again as stated in the march
for our lives mission statement how do
we do this they've got three hallmarks
here
one let's find the assault weapons for
[Applause]
assault weapons that they use for
recreation please man let us take one
for the team here set it down
no
number two
let's just set it down
[Music]
high capacity magazine strength
to hunt migratory burns
do the math you get my point
the third one
[Music]
let's better regulate the background
checks that are already in place yes and
close the loopholes that exist in those
background checks now
okay so here's the thing
i just tend to think he's not that
educated
i don't want to say not that bright
but now people want to want to champion
i mean have you seen him he was on i
think it was on with jordan peterson's
going you know we have people in this
country they're they're on the extreme
right or they're on the extreme left and
all i see are dead armadillos
and i got a wide open
what does that mean so right there he
said ban assault weapons well it's not a
term that's defined okay that's a trojan
horse magazine capacity ban well the
firearms that are here in this studio
boom gone banned and then he shows a
this is only four years ago that he has
a complete lack of understanding of the
second amendment in comparing it to
shells permitted for hunting migratory
birds the second amendment is not about
hunting that could not be less relevant
well let me ask you are you saying that
we should limit it to that same amount
of shells for home defense no i'm not
okay then what's the limit
the point is you're picking an arbitrary
number and once you pick that arbitrary
number it can be
redistricted something you guys complain
about right so it shows he doesn't
understand the second amendment which is
why when you look at these proposals he
may not know that these new ones are
violations of your second amendment
rights and that they are merely trojan
horses to give government control hey
why would you need an assault weapon i
don't know maybe because uh
three months from now i might have to
fight for gas and a
mad max wasteland
maybe somebody's gonna come to my house
armed and try to kill me because i have
an opinion about abortion that they
don't like i don't know maybe the story
we just covered or maybe three months
good for you you can't make it that long
maybe figuratively not physically but
maybe figuratively if i'm at another
jimmy carter gas line an ar-15 fired
into the air a couple times can speed
things along a little bit my point is
it's none of your business figuratively
yeah now
here he is so you saw that that's four
years ago that seems pretty cut and dry
here he is today
proposing common sense
gun reform
which is effectively the same thing as
what he proposed four years ago we need
to invest in mental health care
we need to save for schools
sounds great restrained sensationalized
media coverage
we need to restore our family values
okay we need to restore
our american values he thinks that's a
win
and
we need responsible gun ownership and
we need to restore
moving your head like a parakeet
what is that that's him pausing for
applause yeah yeah he does look like a
pediatric fonda and a bird yes
it's a weird
and i i like them until just now
hold on american values i agree with
that yeah but define those american
values responsible gun ownership that
doesn't mean giving up your rights
american values the second amendment is
a part of that yeah it's amendment
number into the cake it's amendment
number two to protect amendment number
one which allows you to express yourself
as an idiot now that's why you're an
actor at the white house right
otherwise we wouldn't have much use for
you matthew why are you there what's
scary to me is there are genuinely
people in this country going oh my god a
shooting what does dwyane wade think
quick someone get matthew mcconaughey
and we'd like to think no one does that
there are people who i've met those
people yeah i've met those people
we should trust him
remember those are good commercials yeah
look he sold a lot of cars he did he saw
a lot of cars he also does a wild turkey
thing by the way his wild wild turkey is
my favorite bourbon his sucks
it's like this he's like i work together
i didn't just want to come in and just
sail someone else's bourbon eye we're
going to tell a story oh a story of the
shittiest wild turkey in their lineup
yes let's say you're just high in your
house right and you're naked playing the
bongos
as one as one
does
or you're driving a lincoln yeah drunk
on my bourbon i made in my tub yes
make sure you tell the cops how you got
that one so the story of who you just
hit so here there he just said some
stuff that all right okay nothing
objectionable there
um nothing poignant really though right
so what does he mean by responsible gun
ownership now we get to non-specifics
but we know what the specifics are as
far as legislation that he would be
supporting here he is we need
background checks already
we need to raise the minimum age to
purchase an ar-15 rifle
221 why
we need a waiting period for those
rifles we need red flag laws and
consequences for those who abuse them i
agree with the last part these are
reasonable consequences tactical
regulations
to our nation states community schools
and
homes responsible gun owners
are fed up
with the second amendment being abused
and hijacked by some deranged
individuals hey really quickly everyone
in here
i'm pretty sure every who here is a
responsible gun owner in the studio
tool man you you literally wear a cape
of guns what are you talking about he
didn't raise his hand oh i'm switching
the button all right fine
he's also a responsible he's like the
willard of guns yeah oh i've seen him
yes i buy mine in the park off some kid
in a paper bag but does matthew
mcconaughey speak for anyone here just
to be clear no okay just to be clear i
waited for mine for a bit because i have
a criminal record and i expected to
right yeah you had to go through that
process i totally understand that yep
actually i have some questions
regarding that afterwards because i
don't know the process regarding kind of
your criminal because there's a
difference between violent felonies
right not being able to own firearms
yeah if it's a d if it's a drinking
thing or whatever and then it's been so
many years and you know it doesn't it's
not the same we should do a segment on
that and tell people what it was because
a lot of people aren't even aware of
that process yeah they look at it and
i'm not aware of that process because i
haven't been thrown in jail 13 times
right not to judge well no they they uh
they they didn't look at my juvie thank
goodness right yeah otherwise they would
have been like this isn't for you right
yeah
oh hold on a swastika tattoo on his
chest
and i was the worst kid i don't want to
shoot up the school i just didn't want
to go there exactly at all yeah you were
probably safer at home oh please so
let's get through this so what he just
makes you rattles those off let's go
through so the claim that he makes okay
and this is a common claim we need
background checks that's what he wants
to say we need better background checks
truth background checks are already a
thing yeah okay background checks are
already a thing and you can go and watch
or change my mind where i brought those
girls back to the gun range everyone
here you know walther's a sponsor
they've shipped guns to firearms to ffs
we've all had to go there fill out a
background check dave had to wait some
extra time because of his past there's a
an additional process that takes place
it already exists what the left wants
and they use the term background check
these universal background checks these
would of course basically institute a
federal gun registry
it simply could not work without a
federal gun registry background checks
already exist they say oh private
transfers
so we need a
we need a universal background checks
look if you guys don't understand the
problem with a national gun registry
look to canada look to uh australia look
to news look what has happened across
the globe
it's wrong in other words if you have a
federal gun registry you might as well
disarm the population yeah and by the
way they talk about straw purchasers in
this and i'm like okay that's somebody
who's already breaking the law this
wouldn't fix that and all
most of what you said you saw at gun
shows is like people are not sitting
there selling ar-15s nearly as much as
they're selling like more expensive
shotguns and antique rifles right things
to each other it's incredibly rare to
show loophole that they always want to
pull out of course and by the way when
you're looking at these shootings these
shootings did not take place from people
who purchase firearms through gun show
loopholes a big reason for that is if
someone's going to do a private transfer
which is what they're talking about it's
not something you can do online from
house to house okay for example
uh if
i transferred uh or my father had a
firearm transfer down to him from like
from his relative right an old firearm
that was used in the military they can
write it privately between each other
and of course this assumes that no one
is a criminal and you can have it as a
bill of transfer and it's usually used
between family members guess what you're
on the hook if someone misuses that
firearm so there's an incentive to be
very meticulous to be a little choosy
with anyone you do that with and again
statistically it's insignificant in
contributing to any of these shootings
what they are talking about is not
something designed to address private
transfers between family members and
family heirlooms what they are
suggesting is
federal gun registry so when you hear
universal background check
do you support a federal gun registry do
you want the government to know how many
guns you have and where you have them
because of course there's also been a
proposal as you see in california uh
ammo yeah having to be registered do you
want you want everyone to know
okay here's another claim that he made
because in 2020 there wasn't a lot of
ammo right
yeah
uh we need a minimum age to purchase an
ar-15 to be 21. well first off i mean
before we get to the truth the question
is why
but here's a truth that is relevant uh
most firearm homicides are committed
with handguns
not rifles
handguns 59 rifles three percent that's
not even just
ar-15 that's all rifles yeah it's
actually a good point because i was
thinking about the 21 thing and thought
it made sense but that
well here's the thing you have to be 21
in most states to purchase a handgun
already that's what i thought yeah not a
rifle and the reason why because kids
hunt younger a big reason for that right
so they want to save for ar-15s well
hold on a second is this political
theater
again let's look at the stats
90 i think it's 94 percent of shootings
in gun free zones
right you go okay there seems to be a
correlation there versus
three percent of gun homicides involving
rifles hold on a second i know
correlation doesn't equal causation but
isn't the difference of 90 percent more
significant shouldn't we maybe be
looking at the danger of gun-free zones
instead of saying we need a 21-year-old
age limitation on purchasing rifles
which aren't used in most gun homicides
anyway again you need to be 21 to
purchase a handgun in most states just
like in illinois right home of
cook county illinois oh a record 1 000
two gun murders in 2021 chicago the
bastion of freedom and hope texas 21
years old to purchase a handgun
just to be clear
what's
i guess i have a question about the
registry because i you do have to
register in michigan in michigan you do
yeah yeah you don't have to do that in
every state oh you don't no okay i had
to register with your local police
department yeah you do yeah yeah okay i
don't know if that was a common no it's
not a federal thing okay and even then
i'm not comfortable with states forcing
you to register your firearms that was a
big problem a lot of people have with
michigan but they want it to be
registered with the federal government
which you know just imagine it's like
yeah this wouldn't relate to i don't
know mao hitler stalin
even just places like australia beto
o'rourke they wouldn't make use of a
federal
firearm registry to go when they want to
ban guns which is what they said you
have a guy saying hell yes we're going
to take your ar-15s away no no no no we
just want there to be a gun registry so
that i can know
who has ar-15s which by the way i told
you i want to take away it's a trojan
horse yeah what purpose does the gun
registry serve just think it through
like there's there's no legitimate
purpose for it other than that and uh
here's another here's another truth um
investigating i'm not even truth it's
just look if you need to be
a point like no it doesn't matter this
is just this is just my opinion it's
conjecture if you need to be 21 to buy
an ar-15
okay um how about having to present id
to vote
[Music]
yeah no no totally totally take that
deal and you get one ballot right
i would actually be for raising the age
of course residence is uh which again
you can go and check out the banned
episodes on lot of credit.com slash
modclub yeah yeah regarding the election
areas because
i will say this on youtube it's not like
dave drove to addresses for people and
people to address that didn't exist
where people voted on this camera none
of this happened you can't go to lot of
car.com mug club to watch it on camera
not real here's another clip dave wasn't
terrified no
dave was in the worst neighborhood in
america it wasn't the neighborhood that
was scaring him but he was being
followed
right here's another claim that he just
made there and he rattled him off really
quickly while going
i made my point
he says that ar-15 style weapons should
require a waiting period look this is
something that's pretty tough to get
empirical data on so i'll acknowledge
that
uh all references are available a lot of
credit.com for everything else that i've
discussed here
i'll just state that's a fundamental
violation of your second amendment right
when they say this is not a violation of
your second amendment right forcing
someone to wait to purchase a firearm in
many instances people are looking to
purchase a firearm because they need it
for protection yeah
that happened with
me
i don't know if you know this yeah
sometimes we get some threats no
sometimes once some maybe we had a
perhaps would-be break-in that occurred
and we said oh my gosh we have to make
sure that we can protect this place and
uh by the way it puts people's lives in
jeopardy of course um we have it i think
we talked about this before yeah the
truth is there was a new jersey woman
who was murdered by her ex-boyfriend
waiting for a permit against whom she
had a restraining order yeah exactly
well the rand corporation did a study on
this and they actually found that these
waiting periods basically don't give you
any prevention or any significant
prevention at all of gun crime the only
thing that they can potentially help
with and they even had issues with this
was suicides yeah suicide's common
commonly they're like a peak experience
where that kind of tapers off over time
right they even said the waiting period
that they've proposed which i think was
like a three-day waiting period so that
that can persist for weeks right maybe
it's not as high in the peak but that
that feeling can persist four weeks and
so there's really no evidence
specifically no evidence that this would
help for mass shootings but gun crime in
general yeah well and if you're serious
about it i mean you never know right it
can be up and down i mean that's a
difference exactly you know it's a yeah
that's a tight rope you just can't well
yes it's a tight rope in the sense of
what can you do to help those people but
you don't end up helping them by
stripping other people of the rights hey
i have a training order this guy tried
to rape me and he said he's coming back
to rape me tomorrow oh okay we'll come
back in 30 days and let's see if he's
cooled down what yeah the cooldown
period the rapist isn't going to cool
down well you never know hope for the
best look
it's your right to defend yourself and
particularly again when we were talking
about women
you know who needs
firearms in this country
women
and you know who this hurts the most
women who maybe need to protect
themselves from someone who has
premeditatedly premeditatedly told them
they're going to cause them look let's
think about this for a second let's
think of a waiting period is the waiting
period going to negatively affect
someone who is a psychopath who is
planning out a mass shooting no you
don't think he can plan around three
days seven days 30 days depending on
what's proposed the person it hurts is
someone who is them who has been thrown
against their will into a violent
situation who needs to protect
themselves not the person who's planning
the violence right it is a policy that
would directly and almost exclusively
impact those looking to purchase
firearms for self-defense not those
looking to purchase firearms to cause
damage it doesn't pass the logic test
here's another claim that he made we
need red flag laws
all right look let's go i do agree with
the point that he made consequences for
those who abuse them now yeah
here's the problem
he says that
the currently proposed legislation
doesn't include any punishments for
falsely reporting
right so in theory i understand red flag
laws could be useful now what do i mean
someone who says i am going to go shoot
up a school and tells you they are going
to go shoot up a school and post on
facebook and on twitter and on snapchat
that they're going to go shoot up a
school or tells you that they are
violent or tells their uh qualified
therapist that they are thinking of
committing violence right i understand
that concept of red flag laws and that
is something that could be worked in now
i don't want someone losing the right to
firearms because they need a xanax
because they're going through some kind
of a tough scenario they just got fired
laid off or i don't know their woman
took half their crap after they cheated
on them in california the point is i
don't want red flag laws to be abused
how about this let's make this agreement
tomorrow it's nowhere in the legislation
red flag laws
with stipulations as to what would
qualify and if someone abuses it minimum
10-year prison sentence
federal penitentiary plus a hefty fine
is that a common is that is that a
common ground no that makes sense well
it's like the see see something say
something it's like how about do
something then right because how many
times have has have these people been
reported in school shooters where it's
like yeah he's in the backyard shooting
this gun off every single day target
practice and they don't do anything
about it right
so what's the point right you know
these laws only exist if you're actually
going to take them seriously yeah
exactly and that would be going to be
flagging it to the guys who are
masturbating to child pornography on cia
computers and not prosecuting a man
who's sexually assaulting right but
you're right if there is that element of
punishment in it you know it's going to
be taken seriously because there's that
element of punishment also i think that
if we were to do it i think you would
have far more people in prison for
abusing red flag laws than uh people
being uh abused with red flag laws so i
actually would support that just because
i would like to see all the cairns of
the world be sent to prison for falsely
flagging neighbors they don't like who
went out on an ammo run let's see what
they're talking about on cnn here um
they must i love the lower chiron
because it says
detained with weapon detained near
kavanaugh's home yeah the motive of this
person did they say that when they were
talking about gretchen whitmer when the
guys were a state away
fbi they were trying to kill gretchen
how about when the guy was in delaware
going for yeah yeah yeah i know he tried
to kill me yeah the longest shot and
recorded yeah i think i could have been
in france i barely got out by the skin
in my teeth whereas this guy is in the
front yard of kavanaugh saying hey come
out come out wherever you are so i may
kill you yeah yeah he was closer than
aoc was to the actual january 6 oh yeah
i almost died how so i was very far away
how about you just say man tries
man arrested on way to murder judge
kavanaugh because we all said you should
get in the streets and be violent that
should be an attempted murder charge by
the way yeah how about you just say man
with gun tried to kill brett kavanaugh i
would take that yeah there we go but
there's no saying near you don't need
columbo to figure out his motives like
well hold on these are the people who
are proposing red flag laws yeah
think about it they won't even say this
guy said he wanted to kill brett
kavanaugh well there's your tip yeah we
broke the story before them by the way
yes of course we did great job
great job ginger snap they were like
okay how do we make this seem as benign
as possible oh he had a gun
he had a weapon weapon weapon yeah he
had a weapon don't even say gun it was
nunchakus i love the idiot neighbor that
docks them it's like how do you like
that now yeah do you really like all the
riff raff in your neighborhood people
walking up and i hope they violate this
on accident
they have the wrong address because it
has smeared on their poem right if i was
kavanagh i'd go out and switch the
numbers in the night yeah yeah
if that was brett kavanaugh i would open
a private second story shooting range
right at their master bedroom in my
house
sorry that's what an idiot it's like you
live here yeah why would you do that
well because they never come for them
don't you know that the mom never comes
for them i'm the same as you i i mean
mine was not as extreme as your case
obviously but it's like death threats
that's why i bought a gun and surrounded
stuff in cameras wait death threat which
which one well no i mean be more
specific
yeah you've had some you've had some
doozies yeah we really have
i and the thing is i can never talk
about the specifics because we don't
want copycats no no but it's it's so let
me really quickly go back to this we're
talking about the red flag laws okay
think about this for a second
the red flag laws as proposed that's the
issue what is the policy proposal of red
flag laws it's just you can report
anyone and we'll see what happens there
are no punishments i agree with
mcconaughey's sentiment if it comes with
severe consequences minimum 10-year
federal penitentiary and let's call it a
half a million dollar fine if you abuse
red flag laws because removing someone's
fundamental god-given rights right abuse
that should come with some serious
consequences but think about the people
who will be in charge of your right to
own firearms if there are no
consequences attached to the red flag
laws keep in mind this is a woman who
was talking in canada talking about
effectively flagging doxing ruining the
lives of truckers who were protesting
lockdowns she's the one who can take
your guns away murder some rights and
freedom that would tell you that but
since you seem to forget that and you're
all loud and proud because
big thoughts and your freaks big ideas
and you wanna
whatever [ __ ] set up hot tubs in
ottawa
it's a small small small industry
smaller than you'd think same with hr
so
if you're looking for a job
or maybe trying to keep a job maybe
just maybe
think about what you're putting on
social media
is that recruiters talk
and recruiters
like the majority of canada don't agree
with you do you know what that means do
you have any guesses yeah i guess is
what that means what that means
is that if you need a job you might not
get one
if you want to keep a job you might not
get a place job with gun
and
you know what else hr is good at having
cataracts documentation
to you and we hate you
we hate you so much oh yeah but we think
we can't do anything but we can
we
have the power
always remember that
that's a weak human being and that's a
dangerous human being weak people are
dangerous people all of a sudden she got
power through a bureaucracy because
she's a member of hr and she's talking
about ruining the lives of children by
removing the livelihood the ability to
make a living from their parents and she
takes glee in it let me be clear i don't
hate matthew mcconaughey i don't even
hate former vice president joe biden i
hate what they're trying to do i hate
that they're trying to take away our
rights that lady hates you now this is
canada keep in mind they don't need to
be concerned with red flag laws because
you can't purchase firearms anyway but
imagine that broad in charge of your
ability to protect your family that's
what happens if you have these red flag
laws with no consequences you were
raising your hand i wanted to go to one
last point well i was going to say that
you know when you're talking about this
not only is it that the person but the
flawed system that we were talking about
with the fbi that transfers to all of
these branches of government some people
have said oh we just need a waiting
period some people get flagged for an
additional three-day scrutiny right
because they they have it they can't
complete the background check in time
there were over 200 000 cases of people
having to wait 88 days yeah and then
finally the system at the statutory
limit just kicked it out basically so
this is the system you're going to
entrust to have a waiting period
they're not efficient at doing anything
guys do you really think that they're
going to be able to do a three-day
waiting period for everybody oh it's
going to be just fine it's going to be
fantastic even though it doesn't work
the system wouldn't even be able to
handle it i told this story at the time
uh
at the time she was
at the time she was my girlfriend
another fiancee wife so uh she was
living in michigan and the first firearm
that she purchased
uh
i i i can tell the story and then i'll
give you this final stat on mass
shootings just so you know that this is
all predicated on a lie which i think is
important um
she was doing her laundry her roommates
were gone um she lived in a house with
like three roommates when she was in
college and one had moved out and then
one was gone for the weekend and i
remember talking to her on the phone and
i was talking to her on the phone and
she was doing laundry and she was on the
first floor and she said she just felt
weird she heard something at the back
door she went back checked it locked it
there was a man who was up at her window
while she was folding laundry she could
see him out of the corner of her eye
at the window jiggling the window trying
to get in so he knew that she was there
geez he wasn't looking to get into an
empty house
she walked out of the room she ran out
to her car she called the police
turns out there was a sex offender who
was trying to break in someone who had
raped some people in this area of town
she went and she purchased a smith and
wesson j frame revolver which by the way
is like a bomb going off in your hand i
was very impressed that she was able to
shoot it as well as she was uh she lived
in an area
she wasn't going to be able to move out
she was a college student so again the
red flag laws firearms are a great
equalizer for not only women but the
poor
we can't just afford to move we can't
afford to stay in a hotel we can't
afford to have armed security but you
know what if you can go and you can
purchase a firearm and know how to use
it responsibly at least it gives you a
fighting chance against the rapist at
your door jam
she needed a gun then
and that's a huge percentage by the way
of first-time gun buyers just to be
clear why do you think gun sales
skyrocketed during these riots across
the country it's a it's a losing issue
for democrats it is a losing issue for
the left they know it and so that's why
i have to ram it through largely by
executive order and by the way this is
all based on you know matthew
mcconaughey dwyane wade they're all up
there
and the only reason they have a platform
for which they're grossly unqualified is
because a lot of americans believe
and this is because of what we see in
the media that there's this there's this
dramatic increase in mass shootings and
that we're the only country where this
happens we've already debunked this myth
before but there's been new data that's
actually come out uh and it was just uh
recently referenced um well i think we
have it right here we have the reference
availability of cutter.com let me it's
uh there's a 2008 study by john r lot
the us account for about 10
yeah 2018. yeah sorry i said 2008 yeah
red flag me even closer he's he has
cognitive decline well you know what
vice president first so youtube just
shut us off
john r lot this was a study conducted by
john a lot the u.s accounted for about
one percent of the mass public shooters
between 1998 and 2015.
mass shootings first off we're not the
number one country in the world for mass
shootings we're not even the number one
country in the first world for mass
shootings to be clear certainly not for
violent crime and certainly not even for
gun homicide but mass shootings actually
rose faster outside of the united states
than within the united states for that
reporting period and you can look at the
graph it's actually pretty startling
where you can look at mass shootings and
how they increased versus what happened
in the united states now i know it's
terrible whenever it happens
and we all know that our hearts break
everyone's heart is broken okay no one
has the corner on outrage or on
heartbreak over this the problem is they
want to keep this in front of you
non-stop so that they can ram through
something that is unconstitutional and
it's based on a lie don't buy the bill
of goods that they are selling it's not
true and this is why truth matters not
my truth not dave's truth not the
abortion wnba protesters truth both the
same right they probably think that
they're a size two that's they're true
the truth oh lord
the truth is this isn't a more violent
country than other countries the truth
is we don't lead in mass shootings the
truth is that firearms save far more
lives than they take and robbing people
of the right to own firearms is not only
unconstitutional but it will take far
more lives than they save
period it's irrefutable they don't even
try and refute it that's why they make
[ __ ] up like firearms being the leading
cause of death for kids
which we addressed yesterday i think
that's just the president being an idiot
and reading what's handed to him
i'm surprised he can read well baby
steps large font but you know what i
think it's being set into his earpiece
yeah well that's true by barack obama
and i don't know and that's why i've
been very careful with matthew
mcconaughey i i think i'm going to
assume and i do believe he wants to do
good and i think unfortunately he's
probably someone who's only awakened to
informing themselves of these issues
more recently in life didn't seem to
take an interest he seems to have said
that he hasn't taken an interest so
which is it mr mcconaughey i would love
to have you on this program and i i know
that you're used to a lot of softball
programs out there who just let you say
central centrist and that's fine that
won't be me be respectful
but i do want to know what you mean when
you say consequences for red flag laws i
do not want to know what you mean when
you say
waiting periods i do want to know how
you are defining assault weapons because
i know that you have political
aspirations
and guess what if you want to if you
want to reach young people well the way
to them is through here it's not even
close so i'd love to host you and
actually get you to at least clarify it
which i know you don't have time to do
when you're there with a jean-pierre
who's never met a camera that she didn't
like all right we're gonna play pokemon
or racial slur which if this has not
been a reason to be removed from youtube
what and we got a cultural
appropriations tomorrow that's right
tomorrow cultural appropriation month
send in your costumes south africa
yeah no
no murky dangerous territory there no no
no no no
did we get the blood diamond i asked for
oh fantastic amen all right so uh we
will see you tomorrow cultural
appropriation with about the play uh oh
yeah pokemon or racial slur youtube piss
off
you